ليست فقط رموزا رياضيه بل هي ايضا مفاتيح
النجاح في حياه المغني الاكثر شهره في
العالم
بعد ان كان طفلا متلعثما خجولا ينتقده
زملائه فما قصته ولد ادوارد
في المملكه المتحده عام
1991 وهو من عائله فنيه والده جون شيرين
مدرس فن وشقيقه الاكبر ماثيو ملحن
للموسيقى الكلاسيكيه ترعرع عائد في
فراملنج هام انجلترا لكن والديه استمر
بالسفر حيث عزف الموسيقى في انحاء انجلترا
عندما كان طفلا خضع اد لعمليه جراحيه بشكل
خاطئ وتركته يعاني من كسل في العين
ومشكلات حاده في النطق ما جعله يرتدي
نظارات كبيره ويتلعثم في حديثه وهذا ما
متراجعا دراسيا وعرضه للتنمر من زملائه في
المدرسه فكانت الموسيقى ملاذه حيث وجد
نفسه حرا وهو يعزف او يغني بدا الغناء في
جوقه الكنيسه وهو في الرابعه فقط كما اتقن
بعدها العزف على الجيتار بموهبه لافته قبل
ان يبدا بكتابه الاغاني عندما كان في
الرابعه عشره فقط لم يكن علاج النطق عند
سهلا وكان احد اكبر مخاوفه انه سيكون على
هذا النحو لبقيه حياته لكن الامور تغيرت
عندما احضر له والده تسجيلات لمغني الراب
فاندهش من سرعه ادائه واستلهم منه الغناء
وحفظ كل كلمه حتى اختفى ثلاثمه رغم صغر
سنه اقام ايد العديد من الحفلات الموسيقيه
وكان لديه اثنى عشر عرضا غنائيا في
الاسبوع ولم يمضي وقت طويل بعد ان كان
يسجل بالفعل الاقراص المدمجه ويبيعها ثم
اصدر في عام 2005 اول البوم له بعنوان ذا
اورنج روم اي بي كان حينها في الخامسه
عشره من عمره ثم واصل العمل ليصدر البومين
قبل ان يترك المدرسه ويذهب الى لندن
لمواصله مسيرته الموسيقيه في لندن عمل اد
على اصدار البومه الموسيقي يونيدمي كما
انهى فيلمه ايبيلوز الذي يتضمن اول اغنيه
فرديه له
التي تصدرت العديد من القوائم في عده دول
كما وقع في نفس العام مع شركه اتلانتك
ريكورد وايضا ابرم عقدا مع شركه اسايلم
ريكوردز منذ توقيعه مع اتلانتك باع اد
ملايين التسجيلات وحاز على جائزه بريت
كمغنن وعازف منفرد وظهر في افتتاح دوره
الالعاب الاولم
وفاز بجائزه جرامي لاغان مثل
بالاضافه الى البوميه
كما عرف باعمال فنيه اخرى كالتمثيل وانتاج
الاغاني وكتابتها والتلحين وغيرها اليوم
في رصيد ادشيرن الذي يصنف كافضل مغني
عالمي 65 اغنيه وثروه تقدر بنحو 200 مليون
دولار مع محبه ملايين المعجبين حول العالم
التي لا تقدر بثمن
[موسيقى]